would you like to live
forever
well that may not be possible yet but
what if i told you your body could
technically last
for
150 years
what do you need to do to live that long
why would you need to rethink all of
your habits
and how would the world change if
everyone had a long life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if everyone lived for
150 years
the oldest person who's ever lived was a
french woman jean-claude
she passed at the age of
122 years and
164 days
that's way more than the global average
life expectancy of
72.6 years
and even that is optimistic for men
living in central africa whose life
expectancy is 51 years
so what's the secret to living a long
life
one recent study put it simply
we need to remove the usual stressors
related to aging such as diseases and
accidents
and we need to figure out ways to
replace body parts faulty organs and
tissues just like we do with our cars
okay so let's say we already have that
covered and everyone can live for 150
years
now what
well we'd have some significant issues
to figure out the most pressing would be
food
with people living longer we could
expect population growth and more mouths
to feed in a world that already faces a
food gap
the most obvious solution would be to
reduce food waste about 25
of food produced goes uneaten
we could also think about other ways of
farming such as city gardens or urban
rooftops
these would come in handy especially if
we consider that our food production is
not sustainable it contributes about 30
percent of greenhouse gas emissions and
takes up to 40 percent of our land
and
we'd need some of that land to make room
for the growing population
we might also need to consider a
plant-based diet
yeah that's because beef is more
resource intensive to produce and
requires 20 times more land than
plant-based products
it's also inflammatory which can work
against our plans to live longer
but you wouldn't need to go full on
vegan
fish seafood and eggs provide some
important nutrients so you would have to
include those in your diet
[Music]
you'd also need to add in a few years of
work
that way everyone would contribute to
the economy
increase tax revenue for pensions and
keep a sense of purpose
believe it or not working for a few more
years may have its benefits
but with more people needing work the
work week could be four days
or the work day may be shorter
and a longer work life would allow you
to make more career changes to stay
fulfilled
you know what else you'd likely be
switching a lot
romantic partners
on average a marriage lasts seven years
if everyone lived for 150 years
it might be more reasonable to have
multiple marriages than stick with the
same person for
120 years on the other hand you'd
probably have fewer children and they'd
come later in life
you know the oldest woman to give birth
was 73 years old
well this might be the new age for women
to have their kids if we live for 150
years
animals that live longer tend to have
fewer offspring so
that may end up being the case with us
if we think about the size of the
population
having fewer children might also make
more sense in the long term
you know living for 150 years might seem
far-fetched but it'll likely be a
reality really soon
if we make the changes needed to have
resources available for everyone
it could be pretty cool
imagine how many times you could
reinvent yourself
and all the things you could see and
experience with so many years of life
maybe you'd even live long enough to see
the age of human space travel
but that's a story
for
another what if